if Tiger forced to play off with Paul
Casey I I'd like to know what kind of
dent that that would have put into that
selection show Steve since Golf Channel
NBC reporter play-by-play host he was
part of the coverage there Steve joins
us now Steve how are you
fantastic there the first text I got
yesterday what I got in the car to drive
home after the tournament was exactly
that point a buddy of mine said jokingly
I want to thank Tiger for not making
that putt at the last so I could go
watch the selection show if I would have
told you though a month ago Tiger has a
chance to force a playoff at the Valspar
what would you said I would have told
you to have another first of all he's
never played the Valspar and Tiger has
throughout his career Dan as you know
played literally the exact same
tournament you know he's almost the same
schedule every single year so for him to
a add a new event to his repertoire was
a very big deal and also for him to be
in contention you know so soon into this
comeback I thought it was an extremely
big deal so it was kind of a an
excellent cornello therefore the sport
should be pump the brakes and all on
this I would you know I think that
winning in this sport is perhaps you
could make a strong case that it's not
but I think it's perhaps the most
difficult thing to do in all the sports
and here's why Fred Couples is an
all-time great player dad he's in the
Hall of Fame he won 15 times on the PGA
Tour
in 30 years it's a half a tournament a
year and he's in the Hall of Fame so
it's really really hard to get to the
finish line and then cross it and you
know Tiger had it right there
you know if this was tennis he had it on
his racquet he was leading at one point
earlier around after he birdie but first
he had to share the lead everybody else
was crumbling around him Brandt Snedeker
didn't play well you know tough spot for
Brandis
a guy in a great player but is the first
time you've been in it in a long time
Justin Rose didn't perform well Corey
Connors at no chance was the first time
he was ever in that situation everybody
else was crumbling around him like the
old days and Tiger just couldn't quite
get it in deer because it's just hard to
do it then really hard but I would pump
the brakes yeah it's it's a process for
him and we'll see how this week fares at
Bay Hill when you talk to him after the
round I like it in all my I thought he
was almost surprised at that experience
of being back in the mix that that he
forgot what it felt like yeah I I got a
sense that he was a little bit
boy I'm getting teased I've interviewed
a guy a thousand times after wins and
after losses and normally after a loss
he's he's he's not happy he is a not
happy camper I didn't sense that
yesterday because I think again it's all
part of the process I thought it was
really interesting again that he hit an
iron off the last he and not a 3-wood I
didn't expect him had a driver there he
needed 30 you know after making that
electric birdie at 17 from 44 feet and I
I did not expect him to lay up there
with an iron at the last at the par-4
18th
maybe that speaks to where his level of
confidence where his level of comfort is
in that situation as well
one final note here and this bothered
the Dan Hanson it was brought up in the
morning meeting and I know that you're
gonna this is controversial here Patrick
Reed wearing the same shade of red as
tiger on Sunday it's not the first time
he's done it but the Danites have a
problem with that didn't didn't Tiger
sort of stake his claim to that then he
owned that he does on that and he did
stake his claim to it and he's done
pretty well with it over the years was
79 wins and 14 majors Patrick Reed is
one of those guys who thinks a little
bit outside the box and also is a guy
who's not afraid to speak his mind and
when that first came up years ago
whether it's the Danette
or anybody else in the world of golf or
sports who happened to be upset about it
Patrick said listen I'm doing it as an
homage to Tiger Woods I'm doing it
because Tiger was my guy and I wanted to
be Tiger Woods so I'm gonna dress like
Tiger and to see if I can perform like
Tiger on Sunday
I mean Tigers the king out there Dan
I mean he's the King out there with all
of these young guys and Patrick is not
afraid to emulate it maybe maybe a
little bit too much but that's a tough
spot to try to emulate you know arguably
the greatest player of all time maybe
number two by Jack Nicklaus I'll bother
you this weekend with some text messages
while you're on the air thank you Steve
good to talk to you - that's us Steve
Sam's Golf Channel he'll be part of the
network's coverage Arnold Palmer
Invitational this week in Orlando first
round coverage begins Thursday on the
Golf Channel weekend coverage continues
on NBC for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]